pre-planning is the name of the game in
the entertainment industry more often
than not video games get stamped with
release dates long before they're ready
to hit the shelves and 2018 s release
calendar is already jam-packed with
sensational new titles here are the
games that will blow everyone away in
2018 far cry 5 the latest installment of
Ubisoft's first-person shooter franchise
far cry 5 is set in fictional hope
County Montana in a small town that
seems like a slice of perfection stare a
little longer though and the violence
racial tensions in a faith obsessed sect
emerge from the shadows at the bloody
heart of Far Cry 5 is that very band of
believers hell-bent on seizing a chunk
of the American Midwest and transforming
its residents into god-fearing faithfuls
early reactions to far cry 5 have all
seemed to echo the same sentiment from
the game's captivating landscape - it's
uncanny ability to anticipate modern
cultural and political trends it simply
doesn't get more raw than far cry 5 mark
your calendar for when it releases on
February 27 2018 blood-stained
ritual of the night almost entirely
crowdfunded blood-stained ritual the
night is currently in development with
former Castlevania head honcho Koji
Igarashi unsurprisingly this trippy
side-scrolling platformer has been
marketed as a spiritual successor to the
dark fantasy themed game series but will
feature gameplay that postdates 1997
Symphony of the Night you'll traverse
the monster filled world as miriam a
young orphan plagued by a curse that
slowly turns her skin to crystal
surpassing its Kickstarter goal with
ease a garages return to form looks like
it'll shine in its two and a half
dimensions and knock your socks off in
the process be prepared to buy the game
in March 2018 on a variety of platforms
Monster Hunter World Monster Hunter is a
sensation in the gaming world selling
over 40 million games since the
franchise's debut in 2004 and yet the
series has struggled to gain traction
outside of Japan Monster Hunter World
aims to fix that it says as much right
in the title like before hunters prepare
in town before embarking on excursions
into the wilderness where they'll need
to adhere to carefully plan strategies
in order to
take down the game's massive beasts but
Capcom the games publisher is making
some changes to instead of dropping
through a series of smaller walled off
areas monster hunter world takes place
in an open and dynamic environment
that's right no loading screens the
series of Tori ously deep learning curve
has also been softened and the interface
has been streamlined to accommodate new
players as executive director Konami
Fujioka explained it the grammar of
games in the West is evolving and being
able to say we speak your language is a
great chance to get more people on board
this is a title we're definitely looking
forward to in early 2018 God of War
Kratos is back but this isn't your
father's god of war sure 2018 s
installment in the signature PlayStation
franchise will be just as gloriously
violent as ever and yes the demigod in
the facepaint once again plays god of
wars hero but that's where the
similarities end instead of the
sun-drenched mediterranean this new god
of war takes the action to snowy
Scandinavia pitting our hero against
characters from Norse mythology instead
of the over-the-top Pope vibe that
characterized the original games God of
War has a slower more serious tone this
time Kratos is joined on his quest by
his son Atreus that changes everything
not only does Atreus help his old man
during combat but God of War devotees
know Kratos need for vengeance began
when Ares tricked the warrior into
killing his first family director Corey
Barr log says that Atreus is the
humanity that Kratos has lost he's at
mirror that is reminding him that
there's a different way a way he might
have forgotten long ago but before you
start worrying that God of War trades
action for introspection rest assured
that underneath the mature storyline is
a brutal and exciting adventure in the
classic god of war style albeit with a
more modern flavor instead of fixed
camera angles and linear solutions to
problems God of War gives players the
tools they need to proceed then lets
them find the best solution to the
game's obstacles the tone might be new
but at its core God of War will still be
the god murdering simulator we've all
come to know and love like its hero it's
just grown up a little look for it in
early 2018 System Shock completely
revamped from the 1994 original this
I'm shocked remake takes no prisoners
Portland based developer night dive
studios has enlisted the dazzling team
of industry veterans to craft a
high-powered new game that centers
around a keenly resourceful hacker who's
taken prisoner by a money-hungry
trioptimum executive 2018 System Shock
catapults players into the
post-apocalyptic landscape of Citadel
station which is now inhabited by
brainless robots corrupt cyborgs and
grotesquely mutilated creatures all of
which are engineered to obey the
merciless AI known as sho Dan and if
that wasn't enough night dive Studios
promises the world of System Shock has
never been more immersive or terrifying
than in the upcoming reboot we're
excited to find out if that's true in
the second quarter of 2018 crackdown 3
crackdown 3 was originally supposed to
come out in 2016 and then it was pushed
back to November 7th 2017 now the
open-world adventure is set for spring
2018 will the third time be the charm
Microsoft regrets the delays and admits
it revealed crackdown 3 a few years too
early
hopefully the finished product will be
worth the wait as in previous
installments crackdown 3 lets you
control a super-powered agent who hunts
down criminals but the games real draw
is that you can destroy anything and
everything literally by offloading some
of the game's processing into the cloud
crackdown 3 features fully destructible
environments at least in multiplayer
setting the stage for some truly epic
battles if you can see it you can wreck
it now the developer sumo digital has
the extra time it needs to make sure
crackdown 3 shines the game could
represent a major breakthrough in terms
of technology as well as open-world
warfare
besides blowing stuff up is fun and
crackdown 3 explodes things real good
that's good enough for us
get dropping bombs you drop
Red Dead Redemption - although there's a
- tacked on to the end of its title Red
Dead Redemption - is actually the third
installment in the action-adventure
franchise and the first built from the
ground up eight years after Red Dead
Redemption in 12 years after the
original Red Dead Revolver the follow-up
takes vintage Americana vibes and
Atmospheric inspiration from its
predecessors to bring forth an outlaw
epic featuring plenty of gun-slinging
Cowboys and roughed up rebels we'll have
to hold out a bit longer than originally
planned to get our hands on Red Dead
Redemption and its cast of scruffy
characters but considering the games
near limitless landscape and fierce
narrative the days spent waiting may
well be worth it look for the sequel in
spring 2018 spider-man in insomniacs
upcoming PlayStation 4 exclusive players
will slip into a new version of Peter
Parker's iconic red and blue suit and
guide the wall-crawler through the
island of Manhattan on a map that's
reportedly four times bigger than the
one in the developers last open-world
game sunset overdrive players will swing
between buildings take on Spidey's foes
and use all the tricks and tools at
peter's disposal to rescue civilians and
save the day judging by the game's
extended III 2017 demo insomniac has
lifted the best parts of recent
superhero games and combined them into
something both new and familiar combat
looks like it's inspired by Batman
Arkham City allowing players to sneak in
and swing among the rafters and take
down thugs with various attacks or drop
down to the street level to engage in
some rhythm driven fisticuffs but the
cool stuff for Spidey fans doesn't end
there it looks like the developers are
including some of the newest additions
at the spider-man universe mr- a modern
take on dr jekyll and mr. hyde plays a
prominent role insomniac also confirms
that classic Spidey villains will
surface
the kingpin briefly appeared in Sony's
demo all in all this is a spider-man
that embraces everything that makes the
franchise great retro modern or
in-between spider-man is set to release
in the first half of 2018
anthem Bioware isn't the first developer
you'd expect to make an open-world
multiplayer shooter until now the studio
has stuck almost exclusively to
role-playing games with classics like
Baldur's Gate
- the older public Mass Effect and
Dragon Age but if the games e3 trailer
is anything like the final product the
veteran studio will knock everyone's
socks off who hasn't wanted to fly
around and kick butt with a jetpack
anthem looks like it'll be worth it for
that gameplay hook alone players join
the ranks of the freelancers intrepid
explorers who journey into the
wilderness to fight vicious beasts and
gather loot players can team up to
tackle particularly tough challenges and
anthems sprawling shared world assuming
different classes like the all-purpose
Ranger or the tank like Colossus each of
which plays a different role in battle
massive shaper storms promise to shake
up anthem with their world altering
consequences while players can zoom
around using the jetpacks built into
their javelin exosuits
flying across the map or taking to the
air to snipe opponents on the ground
maybe a little of Bioware storytelling
magic will rub off on anthem to TrueCar
pitchin lead writer on the first - Mass
Effect games is penning anthems story
hunting for looting games is always
great but having a good reason to hunt
for it is even better if Bioware
confused a strong narrative with
Destiny's addictive gameplay loop anthem
might end up being very very hard to put
down look for it in fall 2018 Detroit
become human david cages games which
skirt the line between point-and-click
adventure and interactive movie aren't
for everyone
heavy rain received positive reviews on
release but some of the game's odder
features haven't aged quite as well
cages follow-up beyond two souls looked
and sounded great but didn't include
much in the way of interactivity but
every time cage and the team at Quantic
Dream put out a new game the formula
gets a little more complex and Detroit
become human might be where they get the
balance between story and action just
right like cages other games Detroit
lets players guide multiple characters
through a branching storyline that
changes based on the users decisions as
in heavy rain death isn't the end either
if one character dies the story
continues and adapt to that person's
absence three androids Kara Connor and
Marcus serve as our guides into a near
future setting where artificial
life-forms struggle to find their place
in the world with the players help
they'll find a way to settle peacefully
alongside humanity take to the streets
and a full-fledged revolution or
something in between
just don't expect any easy
answers cage says there's no big message
to humanity in this game it's just
interesting questions that may resonate
with your own personal values and just
confront you with the consequences of
your actions
Detroit become human is set for release
in 2018 although as of this video it
doesn't have an official release date
Kingdom Hearts 3 at long last it's
coming Kingdom Hearts 2 the last
numbered entry in this Final Fantasy and
Disney mashup came out way back in 2005
and fans have been waiting for a proper
follow-up ever since and now we're
finally getting it as before series hero
Sora and his pals will travel to lands
based on popular Disney properties while
fighting the evil heartless Kingdom
Hearts 3 doubles down in the Disney -
Sora can unleash powerful summon attacks
based on Disneyland and Disney World
attractions while the new settings take
full advantage of Disney's expanded
corporate portfolio that's right both
Pixar and even Marvel characters are set
to make their Kingdom Hearts debut look
forward in 2018 the last night it's that
often that an indie game threatens to
steal an entire III press conference but
in 2017 the last night almost did just
that by fusing a blade runner-esque
environment with modern cinematic
effects and flashy pixel art the last
night uses style and almost brought
Microsoft's presentation to a standstill
the last night started as a small
prototype developed during 2014
cyberpunk jam and designer Tim surae
only decided to flesh out the game into
a fully fledged project after it won the
events top prize as far as the actual
gameplay goes surae described - last
night as a cinematic adventure game
while publisher raw fury says it will
feature a diverse inclusive cast of
complex characters to interact with
through meaningful branching dialogue
hopefully the last world will be a game
everyone can enjoy when it arrives on
the Xbox one and Windows PC in 2018
death stranding the infamously ambiguous
death stranding is a definite
possibility for release in 2018 as its
creator Hideo Kojima has given more than
a few hints that point to a debut
sometime next year
during the 2016 Tokyo Game Show Kojima
stated it will be out before the
Olympics to go a little further there's
a movie called a key
and it will be out before the year in
which Akira is set the former references
the 2020 Tokyo games the latter the year
2019 whether or not it actually arrives
in 2018 death stranding has already
peaked many gamers interest from the
minute we saw a CGI Norman Reedus
cradling a baby on a deserted beach in
the middle of nowhere
we were hooked since then it's been
revealed that Hannibal actor mas
Mickelson and director Guillermo del
Toro have joined the project which
blends open-world gameplay with unique
elements and an intricate plot color us
excited and counting down to the days
until this hopeful 2018 release code
vein when gamers got their first glimpse
of code vain few knew what to make of it
from the team behind the sci-fi action
adventure series God Eater code vein
packs some serious vampire heat throwing
players into a dystopian dungeon to play
a blood sucking revenant with a network
of supernatural powers laid out just
beneath his thumb or rather behind his
teeth as bearing down on some fresh
flesh grants some new unique abilities
ones players can put to the test through
code veins massive interconnected world
get ready to fight the vein in 2018
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]